accept all of your heroes are full of
your Heroes aren't Gods they're just
regular people who probably got good at
One Thing by neglecting literally
everything else what do you think of
that I think yes I've had that
experience a lot where you realize the
humanity of your Heroes it's like Alan
Watts well if you've learned more about
how his days ended it's like oh wow that
contextualizes Alan Watson how dude he
died of alcohol consumption Alan Watts
you can hear him in several times going
I just like drinking you know I just
like it that was kind of a part of his
spirituality in some ways not the
drinking but just like being into what
you're into but he had some speaking
gigs book there was stuff that he was
looking forward to doing in life but he
expired we put people on pedestals we
project onto them based on where I feel
like my inequity is that they fill in
all of the fallibilities that you have
yeah they just provide the screen for me
to constantly criticize myself in order
to get better and it's been a big part
of like coming to terms with how life
ends up really working